is it too late now to say sorry Justin
Bieber is sure hoping it's not because
he has officially cut his tour short but
why hey friends this is the daily Denney
and I am afraid the show is over no not
this ones let Bieber's the Biebs
abruptly cancelled the remaining 14
stops on his purpose world tour
now his camp told us in a statement it
was due to quote unforeseen
circumstances while a source told ET
after a hundred and fifty shows on six
continents he's tired and needed a break
well here's what Justin had to say for
himself you have to come to the tool man
is everything okay oh yeah yeah just
just not enough event on the road or
yeah a long stretch right looking
forward to sundown fun relaxation right
the place nice any message for the fans
I love you guys and you guys are awesome
sorry for anybody who feels like
disappointed or betrayed how might you
may feel disappointed and betrayed but
John Mayer was quick to defend Justin's
move he tweeted when someone pulls
remaining dates of a tour it means they
would have done real damage to
themselves if they kept going he added
we've lost so many great artists lately
I give Justin thumbs up for realizing it
was time to call it you should too I
gotta say I agree with mayor let's be
honest Justin Bieber has been on an
emotional roller coaster since this tour
began literally there has been so much
crying and in between the cries he
butchered the lyrics to a song despot
Seto and in December he even schooled to
fans at a concert for wait for it
screaming at the top of their lungs oh
and there was also that time he was
spotted up in a tree walking around
barefoot and sucking on a pacifier but
looking back maybe we should have seen
it all coming and I think the boy needs
to call it but what do you guys think
should Justin have power through or is
it time for him to reset coming up you
guys we got to talk about Drake's new
tattoo of little Wayne but before that
let's move on to Chrissy Teigan Chrissy
has earned the ad
raishin of so many fans online 6.4
million on Twitter to be exact
but she just lost one notable follower
in fact he's blocked her and he just so
happens to be the leader of the free
world
that's right President Donald Trump has
blocked Chrissy Teigen on Twitter the
supermodel has slammed him on the
platform before but after years of
condemning him the comment that
apparently crossed the line was quote
lol no one likes you that was in
response to one of the president's
tweets about his disappointment in his
Republican colleagues on Tuesday morning
Chrissy revealed the block tweeting
after nine years of hating Donald J
Trump telling him lol no one likes you
was the straw and that my friends brings
them to a negative 3 on the John and
Chrissy scale now of course Chrissy has
expressed her disapproval of Trump on
Twitter since he was a Republican
presidential candidate she even once
called out that Trump had retweeted a
message from one of his supporters
slamming her saying she didn't hold a
candle to Melania Trump in beauty and
eloquence Chrissy's response the
greatest birthday gift ever something
tells me she's not at home crying over
this and in fact I think we have a shot
of her from just a couple hours ago yep
I'm going to say she good you know who
else is living their best life right now
Drake the dude is no stranger to getting
tattoos that hold a special meaning to
him I mean he's inked up with people he
loves and he just permanently
immortalized a famous face on his person
the rapper shared this photo as he
wrapped up Houston appreciation weekend
and fans were quick to point out his new
ink that face peeking out of his tricep
his little Wayne you see what happens
when you give Drake his big break Wayne
did of course help Drake get his star
after he signed the star to his Young
Money label in 2009 so who's next
my money is on another Canadian great
Celine Dion Drake fanboy over her
backstage at the Billboard Music Awards
in may where someone heard him tell
Celine and I'm not making this up I saw
this he was like a year away from us
lien tat on his rib cage what I want to
know is is anyone crazy enough to get
their idols tattooed on their body
let me see tweet me at D direct o or
leave the pics in the comment section
below so I can pay
mad respect because as much as I love
Beyonce you couldn't pay me to get a tat
of her what can I say I'm a Libra don't
like anything - per minute are you guys
meanwhile Kendrick Lamar has eight new
reasons to be humble the rapper's video
for humble just scored him eight MTV VMA
nominations including video of the year
and best hip-hop video Kendrick was also
nominated for artist of the year the
show's first ever gender neutral
category just like this year's MTV Movie
and TV Awards the VMAs will feature
genderless categories so long gone are
the best male and Best Female Video
categories but I'm hoping we get the
classic VMA Video Music Award moment
give me Diana Ross bluffing little Kim's
boob or conscious during the stage I'm
calling it now I want a surprised Katy
Perry and Taylor Swift duet finally
putting an end to this beast I'm just
putting it out in the universe folks
alright that's it for today you guys be
sure to hit subscribe on e t--'s youtube
channel for more daily denne
and of course head over to ET online.com
where we've got a full list of the VMA
nominations until tomorrow i'm going to
dance my way out of here
you guys know the deal is